Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
el Líbano conocido como la suiza del
medio oriente se encuentra en un momento
crítico a nivel económico social y
político el sistema bancario libanés que
durante décadas ha constituido una de
las principales fuentes de riqueza del
país se encuentra en bancarrota la libre
libanesa ha perdido alrededor del 100%
de su valor en los últimos 3 años y el
coste de la vida ha subido de manera
exponencial debido a la hiperinflación
del
210%. se estima que más del 80% de los
libaneses se encuentran en el umbral de
la pobreza Por otra parte la población
libanesa ha dejado de confiar en sus
líderes las instituciones funcionan a
media máquina o están paradas debido a
que aún no se ha formado Un gobierno y
El Ejecutivo interino no tiene la
capacidad de aprobar presupuestos ni
reformas Líbano ha entrado en una crisis
permanente de la cual no logra salir hoy
nos acompaña etel bonet autora de este
junto a Diego Ibarra Hola ethel
coméntanos un poco de cómo se sienten
los libaneses con toda la situación que
vive el país el informe Mundial de la
felicidad de 2023 de Naciones Unidas
sitúa el Líbano en el penúltimo lugar es
decir es uno de los más infelices
después de Afganistán Cuáles son las
causas que han llevado a los libaneses a
vivir en estas malas circunstancias
el Líbano es un pueblo resiliente que
tras 15 años de guerra civil fraticida
que destrozó el país y las vidas de
cientos de miles de libaneses se
recuperó rápidamente y no solamente eso
sino que se ha convertido en modelo en
la región de una economía creciente sin
embargo y valga la paradoja la economía
neoliberalista que implementó el ex
Primer Ministro libanés asesinado rafit
hariri en la década de los 90 ha sido la
principal causa de que hoy el sistema
bancario libanés esté en bancarrota
Lamentablemente la élite política que ha
gobernado durante más de 30 años no supo
frenar ni cambiar la situación en los
últimos cuatro años el índice de pobreza
que era del 20%, supera ahora el 80% de
la población a esto hay que sumarle el
corralito impuesto por los bancos para
mitigar la crisis financiera
la desconfianza general de los libaneses
a sus gobernantes ya que no han mostrado
ningún signo de voluntad política para
revertir la situación
el panorama es desolador y miles de
familias libanesas viven con dos horas
de luz al día hay escasez de medicinas y
las madres no pueden comprar los
productos básicos para alimentar a sus
hijos porque la moneda local cada vez
vale menos mientras que los precios
suben
7 y qué panorama se presenta para el
futuro del Líbano habría esperanza de
una recuperación económica
la recuperación económica del Líbano es
muy difícil pero no imposible el
principal problema es que debido a que
se han parado las transacciones
económicas por la desconfianza en los
bancos libaneses hay una economía de
efectivo lo que hace que haya más
descontrol financiero para que el país
se recupere es necesario un presidente
ya que desde el pasado mes de octubre no
se ha elegido al nuevo jefe de estado
para poder llevar a cabo reformas
económicas y aprobar una ley de control
de capitales como exige el fondo
monetario internacional el fmi y el
Líbano firmaron el año pasado un acuerdo
por el cual el país recibiría 3.000
millones de dólares si se llevaron a
cabo una serie de reformas económicas el
Líbano también está esperando a recibir
11.000 millones de dólares que
prometieron los donantes internacionales
en la conferencia del Cedro que se le
celebró en 2018 en París pero hasta el
momento no ha habido ningún cambio por
parte de las autoridades es por eso que
el Banco Mundial ha calificado en su
último informe a los líderes libaneses
de haber llevado una inacción deliberada
por el colapso económico del país
veamos la historia
[Música]
se hablaba del Líbano como la suiza
Oriente medio y de beirut como el París
de orión pero el declive económico
social y político de los últimos años ha
convertido a los libaneses en uno de los
ciudadanos más infelices del mundo el
caso de malekustani gerente de
hostelería es un ejemplo de la situación
calamitosa que vive el país siente que
será escapado la última oportunidad para
conseguir un mejor Porvenir una empresa
internacional ofreció en pleno
hospitalidad en la ciudad bucarest pero
la embajada de Rumanía le ha rechazado
la solicitud del visado de trabajo
no sé qué voy a decirle a mi prometida
no me han dado ninguna explicación de
Por qué me han denegado el visado me han
dado un código que tengo que
introducirlo en internet y traducir la
página del
malek y su novia había pertenecen a una
generación de jóvenes cualificados que
se sienten atrapados en el Líbano sin
poder encontrar un trabajo bien
remunerado que les permita realizar sus
planes de futuro quieren casarse pero
debido a la profunda crisis económica
malex sigue viviendo en casa de sus
padres
me siento muy triste cuando veo a
jóvenes como yo e incluso más jóvenes
que acaban suicidándose porque no
encuentran trabajo aquellos que tienen
un empleo les ofrecen menos de mitad del
salario que recibían antes Y con toda
esta humillación siguen aceptando estas
pagas para poder cubrir las necesidades
básicas había planeado casarme este
verano Lamentablemente eso no es posible
ahora pero voy a seguir buscando trabajo
en el extranjero
como padre resulta difícil aceptar la
decisión de que su hijo tenga que
emigrar para tener un pero no puede
ayudarle económicamente Porque todo lo
que tenía lo que había trabajado para
asegurar el futuro de la familia se hizo
pedazos con las explosiones del puerto
de virú
cómo voy a querer que mi hijo se marche
y nos deje solos pero nos vemos
obligados a darnos por vencidos y
aceptar esta realidad de tener que
enviar a nuestros hijos a trabajar en el
extranjero porque aquí no hay esperanzas
para ellos no hay por venir
Así quedó la parte hotel en el tegasana
había invertido sus ahorros tras sus
potentes explosiones del 4 de agosto
2020 el hotel permanece cerrado y sin
poder reformarse a la espera de que se
resuelva la investigación del puerto de
beirut que sigue paralizada para poder
cobrar la indemnización de su compañía
de seguros
nuestros políticos nos han abandonado
nos han dejado a nuestra suerte
tengo problemas de salud y apenas puedo
caminar si no fuera por mi hermano que
vive en Estados Unidos y me está
ayudando con el seguro médico y las
medicinas no podría pagar el tratamiento
el colapso económico está acabando con
la clase media las colas del hambre se
multiplican a medida que la libra
libanesa sigue sumando dígitos como un
ejército derrotado en la batalla
contandola como consecuencia las
condiciones de vida se han deteriorado
para millones de libaneses a sus 70 años
helenbath se ha visto empujada a vivir
de la Caridad que ofrecen asociaciones
benéficas como la que dirige el padre
massi cualquier intento por mejorar es
en vano no entiendo cómo Hemos llegado a
esta situación tengo que mendigar en las
calles para comer uno de mis hermanos
trabaja fuera de beirut y me ha dejado
su casa porque ahora no la está usando
vivo de la Caridad de mi familia y
vecinos
mi hermano Está tratando de encontrar la
manera de migrar con sus hijos y con
suerte me llevará con el más tarde no
tengo nada estoy viviendo en la pobreza
extrema
en el barrio la electricidad apenas
llega dos horas al día y Helen no puede
pagar la costosa cuota del generador
privado para bombear el agua Así que
tiene que llenar recipientes de cocina
para poder asearse en el baño
como puedes ver no tengo agua en casa
mis vecinos me dejan llenar unos galones
de agua en su casa para ayudarme por mi
mala situación al igual que con la
comida gracias al padre Martí puedo
comer
las cocinas de la calidad del padre más
y están llenando los estómagos vacíos de
los más vulnerables ante la falta de
ayudas sociales que el gobierno no pueda
asumir por la sobrecarga de deudas
la situación económica en el Líbano es
extremadamente difícil muchas familias
no pueden ni cocinar en sus casas debido
a los altos precios de los alimentos y
el gas Empecé con un comedor popular
aquí en maba para ayudar a 350 personas
ahora Estamos alimentando a más de 3.000
y llevamos comida preparada a personas
enfermas que no pueden salir de sus
casas pero no hay que olvidar que una
comida al día no es suficiente
las costas de trípoli y la segunda
ciudad del Líbano y también la más pobre
de todo el Mediterráneo son testigos
mudos de la huída se espera de la
miseria de familias como le Ibrahim a
bordo de embarcaciones ilegales Ibrahim
es lanchero y el mar es su fuente de
ingresos pero también la ha quitado lo
que más quería sus dos hermanas
salmanigania murieron ahogadas y sus
cuerpos no han sido recuperados junto
docenas de migrantes más cuando en el
bote en el que también iban el y su
madre se hundió en estas costas el 23 de
abril de 2022
no me queda otra opción más que la de
huir
porque en el Líbano No hay forma de
venir
sea como sea en esta misma lancha o un
bote pequeño sacaré a mi familia Porque
no tenemos nada que perder
nada en absoluto
nos han robado hasta el aliento
trabajo día y noche para ganar nada
No me puedo enfermar porque no puedo
pagar el hospital
nuestros políticos nos están matando
por eso la gente prefiere morir en el
mar
Ibrahim todavía guarda la esperanza de
que sus cuerpos se han encontrados y
puedan enterarlas y descansar en paz al
terminar la jornada de trabajo lo que
más le cuesta es regresar a casa con su
madre María la ausencia salmanigania
está presente en cada Rincón de la casa
para seguir adelante varias se aferra el
recuerdo de sus hijas mantiene la
habitación ordenada y guarda con cariño
los objetos personales de sus niñas para
sentirlas más cerca
Esa es la pijama favorita
estaba tan feliz con sus planes de
casarse que el señor la tenga en su
gloria
varias se siente responsable por el
Terrible destino de sus hijas
yo fui quien insistió en que teníamos
que huir me ofrecieron ir gratis en La
Barca porque todo el mundo sabía lo
mucho que deseaba que nos marcháramos de
aquí
quería que mis tres hijos Ibrahim gania
y salmana tuvieran un futuro
naji que también vino con nosotros en el
bote pudieran casarse y formar una
familia en otro lugar ahora naji ha
perdido al amor de su vida
María cree que el hundimiento el bote
cargado con más de 80 migrantes la
mayoría libaneses no fue solo un
incidente desafortunado en su teléfono
móvil guarda unas grabaciones donde se
oye al Capitán de una de las patrulleras
que interceptaron el bote ordenar hundir
la embarcación
recibimos un primer impacto en la parte
delantera y después en la trasera
tardaron horas en rescatarnos se hizo la
media noche Solo siento vergüenza de
este país
el Líbano naufraga como un barco alegre
y los primeros en abandonarlo ha sido la
clase política la Silla presidencial
está vacante así como están vacías las
oficinas del Gran serai a la espera de
que se nombren los cargos de gobierno el
hartazgo popular contra la élite
gobernante ha abierto el camino una
nueva generación de políticos como Camil
morani que aspiran a renovar la élite
dirigente
Este muro representa lo que los
olivaneses piensan sobre sus líderes
políticos
creo que esta crisis económica es una
oportunidad para que la gente deje
marchar sus viejas afiliaciones
políticos sectarias y mire hacia una
nueva alternativa política seria que
devuelva la esperanza y prosperidad
pero devolver la confianza a la gente a
los partidos políticos no es tan
sencillo para este objetivo la formación
de Camila bloque nacional organiza
charlas semanales para acercar a la
ciudadanía al proceso político que se
encuentra estancado por el colapso
económico el país se enfrenta un momento
muy crítico la presidencia está vacante
desde noviembre y llevamos casi un año
sin gobierno las instituciones están
bloqueadas el índice de pobreza sigue
aumentando y la inflación supera el 200%
nuestra clase política no ha tomado
ninguna de las recomendaciones del fmi
para el rescate
llegados a este punto ellos son el
problema y no pueden ser parte de la
solución
tiene una visión para un plantel de
recuperación económica los bancos
deciden en poner un corralito financiero
a los depósitos bancarios ya han cerrado
de forma indefinida dejando los
ahorradores libaneses desprotegidos por
estas medidas informales desde su grupo
culona ydara la conocida activista y
economista Diana mehmed trabaja con la
diáspora libanesa y expertos
internacionales para encontrar los
mecanismos legales que puedan llevar a
los responsables del colapso financiero
a rendir cuentas es el resultado de más
de 30 años de mala gobernanza y
corrupción en 2011 ya se sabía que el
número de Divisas extranjeras que
entraban al país era mucho menor que las
que salían en vez de tomarse medidas
estrictas para el control de capitales
la clase política decidió darle morfina
al pueblo manteniendo un cambio irreal
respecto al Dólar para que la gente no
sintiera el impacto de la crisis hasta
que nos estalló en la cara en 2019 la
desesperación de los depositantes de no
poder acceder a sus ahorros
ha traído actos de vandalismo en las
entidades bancarias atracos a bancos por
clientes que quieren recuperar su dinero
sucursales bancarias incendiadas por
manifestantes ataques contra la
residencias de los responsables de los
bancos se han convertido en escenas
el mayor de los delincuentes es nuestra
clase gobernante que con sus actos
criminales nos ha llevado a esta
situación deliberadamente no ha hecho
nada en estos cuatro años para mitigar
el hundimiento de la economía es hora de
acabar con el camino de la impunidad las
explosiones hasta el puerto de berup en
2020 fueron el último acto de la
historia del colapso del Líbano aun con
su estructura dañada los solemnes y los
del puerto han aguantado las embestidas
emedio martes escombros emergen como una
silueta quijotesca para entender
resiliencia malek de otros miles de
libaneses para seguir afrontando los
momentos difíciles
[Aplausos]
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
Recuerda que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]